WE WILL ANALYZE ALL OF THIS AND
SO MUCH MORE IN TONIGHT'S VERY
IMPORTANT BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
IF YOU JUST SAW PRESIDENT TRUMP
MOMENTS AGO WRAPPING UP A TOAST
WITH THE FRENCH PRESIDENT AT THE
FIRST STATE DINNER.
THE SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP
BLOSSOMING BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
AND PRESIDENT MACRON.
IT'S ONE ASPECT, HUGE TRUMP
DIPLOMATIC SUCCESS.
REPORT THIS BUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE MAKING
INCREDIBLE STRIDES ALL OVER
ASIA.
IN FACT, WITH EVERY PASSING DAY,
THE U.S. IS NOW GETTING CLOSER
AND CLOSER TO HOLDING DIRECT
TALKS WITH NORTH KOREA.
JUST THIS WEEK, THE DICTATOR
KIM JONG UN MADE A SERIES OF
CONCESSIONS, INCLUDING THE
SUSPENSION OF ALL BALLISTIC
MISSILE TESTING, THE CLOSURE OF
A NUCLEAR DEVELOPMENT SITE, AND
NORTH KOREA'S ROCKET MAN EVEN
DROPPED A DEMAND THAT THE U.S.
TROOPS LEAVE THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
EARLIER TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
LAUDED THE PROGRESS AND EVEN HAD
KIND WORDS FOR KIM JONG UN AND
HIS NEWFOUND WILLINGNESS TO
COMPROMISE ON THE WORLD STAGE.
WATCH THIS.
>> KIM JONG UN REALLY HAS BEEN
VERY OPEN, AND I THINK VERY
HONORABLE FROM EVERYTHING WE ARE
SEEING.
NOW, A LOT OF PROMISES HAVE BEEN
MADE BY NORTH KOREA OVER THE
YEARS, BUT THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN
IN THIS POSITION.
I HOPE THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
DEAL IN A VERY OPEN AND
HONORABLE FASHION WITH
NORTH KOREA.
I STARTED A PROCESS, AND WHAT I
DID, EVERYBODY THOUGHT I WAS
DOING IT ABSOLUTELY WRONG.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, FOR 25
YEARS, PEOPLE HAVE BEEN DEALING
AND NOTHING HAPPENED.
AND A LOT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
I THINK WE ARE DOING VERY WELL.
MEETINGS ARE BEING SET UP, AND I
WANT TO SEE THE NUCLEAR IS A OF
NORTH KOREA.
A LOT OF CONCESSIONS OF ALREADY
BEEN MADE.
WE HAVE MADE NO CONCESSIONS
DESPITE SOME OF THE MEDIA SAYING
THAT I'VE MADE CONCESSIONS.
I HAVEN'T EVEN DISCUSSED A
CONCESSION.
NATURALLY, INSTEAD OF REPORTING
THE DRAMATIC PROGRESS IN THE
KOREAN PENINSULA WHICH THEY
WHOLE WORLD TO SAY.
WORK IF IT WORKS, YOUR
MAINSTREAM MEDIA TWISTING THOSE
REMARKS IN ORDER TO TRASH THE
PRESIDENT ONCE AGAIN AND
DISTRACT THEIR VIEWERS FROM
TRUMP'S UNDENIABLE INITIAL
SUCCESS ALL OVER THE WORLD
STAGE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> HE SAID THAT NORTH KOREA'S
DICTATOR KIM JONG UN HAS ACTED,
HAS BEEN VERY OPEN AND VERY
HONORABLE AND HOW THEY HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH, I GUESS, PLANNING
OUT THEIR MEETING TO COME.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> IT'S QUITE A STRONG ADJECTIVE
TO USE FOR A DICTATOR OF A
NATION THAT IMPRISONS ITS
PEOPLE.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT HOW GREAT
KIM JONG UN IS BEING PAID >> YOU
MUST TALK ABOUT THIS JUST
FOR A MOMENT.
DID HE CALL HIM A GREAT LEADER?
TO GO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU USE
THE WORD GREAT LEADER.
HE SAID HONORABLE.
>> HONORABLE.
>> AND OPEN.
I DON'T KNOW IN REAL TERMS
WHETHER YOU CAN EVER CALL HIM
OPEN.
>> IF ANY OTHER PRESIDENT,
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN, HAD YOU
SEARCHED WORDS, DONALD TRUMP
WOULD'VE BEEN THE FIRST PERSON
TO
SAY IT'S OUTRAGEOUS TO SAY THAT
A DICTATOR WHO REPRESSES ALL
THE HUMAN RIGHTS IN THIS
COUNTRY, LET HIS PEOPLE STARVE,
TAKES AMERICANS HOSTAGE, IS
OPERA AND HONORABLE.
>> WHEN I HEARD THE WORD
HONORABLE, I THOUGHT OF OTTO
WARMBIER'S PARENTS WHO SAT WITH
ME SO MANY MONTHS AGO TALKING
ABOUT THEIR SON WHO WAS TORTURED
IN NORTH KOREA.
HOW IS KIM JONG UN HONORABLE?
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING
HONORABLE ABOUT KIM JONG UN.
HE'S A SOCIOPATH.
>> Sean: YOU SAW THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA ATTACKING THIS
PRESIDENT.
NO MATTER WHAT HE DOES.
IF HE GAVE $10 MILLION TO EVERY
PERSON ON EARTH, THEY WOULD SAY
WHY NOT 11?
I GUESS THEY FORGOT ABOUT
TRUMP'S PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH
OF STRATEGY AND HOW IT'S
WORKING.
WE SENT MULTIPLE CARRIER STRIKE
GROUP TO THE REGION.
WE INCREASED THE SANCTIONS ON
THE ROGUE REGIME.
WE PRESSURED CHINA, AND THEY
HELPED.
OH, YEAH, AND THE PRESIDENT
CALLED OUT LITTLE ROCKET MAN'S
TERRIBLE TREATMENT OF HIS OWN
PEOPLE IN A VERY CLEAR AND
PUBLIC WAY WITHOUT BACKING DOWN.
THE MEDIA IS NOT USED TO THIS.
>> NO ONE IS SHOWN MORE CONTEMPT
FOR OTHER NATIONS AND FOR THE
WELL-BEING OF THEIR OWN PEOPLE
THAN THE DEPRAVED REGIME IN
NORTH KOREA.
IT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
STARVATION DEATHS OF MILLIONS OF
NORTH KOREANS AND FOR THE
IMPRISONMENT, TORTURE, KILLING,
AND OPPRESSION OF COUNTLESS MORE
AND OPPRESSION OF COUNTLESS MOR
MORE.
THE HORROR OF LIFE IN
NORTH KOREA IS SO COMPLETE THAT
CITIZENS PAY BRIBES TO
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS TO HAVE
THEMSELVES EXPORTED ABOARD AS
SLAVES.
THEY WOULD RATHER BE SLAVES.
THEN LIVING NORTH KOREA.
NO REGIME HAS OPPRESSED ITS OWN
CITIZENS MARKED TOTALLY OR
BRUTALLY THEN THE CRUEL
DICTATORSHIP IN NORTH KOREA.
NORTH KOREA'S RECKLESS PURSUIT
OF NUCLEAR MISSILES COULD VERY
SOON THREATEN OUR HOMELANDS.
>> Sean: TIME FOR A HISTORY
LESSON.
REMEMBER IT WAS ONLY A FEW
MONTHS AGO THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
SAID THAT DONALD TRUMP'S TOUGH
ACTION, HIS RHETORIC, IT WOULD
RESULT IN A NUCLEAR HOLOCAUST.
THIS WAS THEIR PREDICTIONS.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE IDEA OF A NUCLEAR
SHOWDOWN WITH NORTH KOREA KEEPS
YOU UP AT NIGHT.
I WOULD RECOMMEND DELETING YOUR
TWITTER APP.
>> HE IS NOT REALLY BEING
CAVALIER WITH A THREAT ABOUT
NUCLEAR WAR.
HE IS BEING CAVALIER IN A WAY
THAT MAKES HIM SEEM DEMENTED.
>> THESE ARE THE MESSAGES FROM A
PERSON WHO IS NOT WELL, FROM A
LEADER WHO IS NOT FIT FOR
OFFICE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOADING
KIM JONG UN TO TEST A NUCLEAR
MISSILE AGAIN, TO PROVE ITS
RELIABILITY, TO SHOW HIM WRONG.
AND FUNDAMENTALLY I THINK IT
COMES ACROSS AS TO
KINDERGARTNERS WHO ARE JOSTLING
EACH OTHER, EXCEPT THAT EACH
HAS NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> TOO LATE AFTER 100,000
AMERICANS DIE.
>> AFTER A NUCLEAR HOLOCAUST.
>> OR AFTER A MILLION DIE.
>> THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
THIS IS NOT AN EXAGGERATION.
>> TRUMP'S COMMENTS HAVE EXPERTS
WORRIED HE COULD INADVERTENTLY
TRIGGER A CATASTROPHE.
>> Sean: LET'S GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
PRESIDENT         PRESIDENT TRUM
PRESIDENT         PRESIDENT TRU
PRESIDENT         PRESIDENT TRUA
PRESIDENT         PRESIDENT TRUE
PRESIDENT         PRESIDENT TRUS
PRESIDENT         PRESIDENT TRUT
PRESIDENT         PRESIDENT TRUU
PRESIDENT         PRESIDENT TRUH
ACTION IN THE MEDIA AS A
MELTDOWN.
THE STRATEGY BRINGS KIM JONG UN
TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE TALKING
ABOUT DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
ENTIRE KOREAN PENINSULA.
THE PRESIDENT MAKES ENCOURAGING
REMARKS, AND THE MEDIA STILL HAS
A MELTDOWN.
DO KNOW WHAT THE MEDIA DIDN'T
HAVE A MELTDOWN OVER?
HOW ABOUT OBAMA'S APPEASEMENT OF
THE MULLAHS IN IRAN, WHAT IS
PROBABLY THE DUMBEST SINGLE DEAL
IN THE HISTORY OF MANKIND WHERE
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
YOUR EX-PRESIDENT GAVE AWAY
150 BILLION OF YOUR DOLLARS,
CARGO PLANES FULL OF CASH AND
OTHER CURRENCIES TO A REGIME
THAT CHANCE "DEATH TO AMERICA.
DEATH TO ISRAEL" ON A WEEKLY
BASIS.
BURNS OUR FLAG, BURNS THE
ISRAELI FLAG ALL BECAUSE OF A
PROMISE FROM IRAN TO TEMPORARILY
HALT THEIR NUCLEAR WEAPONS
PROGRAM.
WE DIDN'T GET TO INSPECT
ANYTHING.
THAT'S THE DUMBEST DEAL EVER.
BILL CLINTON SAID IT'S A GOOD
DEAL FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HIS APPEASEMENT OF NORTH KOREA,
KIM JONG IL, KIM JONG UN'S
FATHER.
THIS DIPLOMATIC DERELICTION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS A GOOD DEAL FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
NORTH KOREA WILL FREEZE AND
DISMANTLE ITS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
SOUTH KOREA AND OUR OTHER ALLIES
WILL BE BETTER PROTECTED.
THE ENTIRE WORLD WILL BE SAFER
AS WE SLOW THE SPREAD OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
SOUTH KOREA WITH SUPPORT FROM
JAPAN AND OTHER NATIONS WILL
BEAR MOST OF THE COST OF
PROVIDING NORTH KOREA WITH FUEL
TO MAKE UP FOR THE NUCLEAR
ENERGY IS LOSING.
AND THEY WILL PAY FOR AN
ALTERNATIVE POWER SYSTEM FOR
NORTH KOREA THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
TO PRODUCE ELECTRICITY WHILE
MAKING IT MUCH HARDER FOR THEM
TO PRODUCE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THE UNITED STATES AND
INTERNATIONAL INSPECTORS WILL
CAREFULLY MONITOR NORTH KOREA TO
MAKE SURE IT KEEPS ITS
COMMITMENTS.
ONLY AS IT DOES SO WILL
NORTH KOREA FULLY JOIN THE
COMMUNITY OF NATIONS.
>> Sean: DIDN'T WORK OUT TOO
IT'S TIME TO LEARN FROM THE
FAILURES ON THE WORLD STAGE.
APPEASEMENT NEVER WORKS.
IT INCURS AGGRESSION.
THIS IS SOMETHING.
FORMER PRESIDENT REAGAN KNEW ALL
TOO WELL WHICH IS WHY HE REFUSED
TO RELENT, REFUSED TO APPEASE,
REFUSE TO PLACATE THE
SOVIET UNION, THE FORMER EVIL
EMPIRE, AS HE DESCRIBED THEM.
BACK THEN BANANA AND LEFT WERE
ALSO PREDICTING THE WORST, THAT
REAGAN WOULD BRING US TO THE
BRINK OF NUCLEAR WAR.
AND WHAT HAPPENED?
THE BERLIN WALL CAME TUMBLING
DOWN.
>> THERE IS ONE SIGN THE SOVIETS
CAN MAKE THAT WOULD BE
UNMISTAKABLE.
THAT WOULD ADVANCE DRAMATICALLY
THE CAUSE OF FREEDOM AND PEACE.
GENERAL SECRETARY GORBACHEV, IF
YOU SEEK PEACE, IF YOU SEEK
PROSPERITY FOR THE SOVIET UNION
AND EASTERN EUROPE, IF YOU SEEK
LIBERALIZATION, COME HERE TO
THIS GATE.
MR. GORBACHEV, OPEN THIS GATE.
MR. GORBACHEV, TEAR DOWN THIS
WALL.
>> Sean: THE WALL CAME DOWN.
WE WILL HAVE MORE IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S SIGNIFICANT
PNEUMATIC PROCESS THROUGHOUT THE
SHOW.
WE WILL SHOW YOU HOW BRIBING
DICTATORS AND KISSING THE RINGS
OF DESPOTS AND MURDERERS HAS
FAILED ALL THROUGHOUT HISTORY.
LET'S TURN TO A BRAND-NEW
EXCLUSIVE REPORT FROM OUR OWN
SARA CARTER UNCOVERING A NEW
REVELATION ABOUT WHAT SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT AT SOME OF THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
ACCORDING TO SARAH, MULTIPLE
SOURCES ARE SAYING FIRED FBI
DEPUTY DIRECTOR ANDREW MUGABE
ISSUED A STANDOUT ORDER DURING
THE INITIAL PHASES OF THE FBI'S
INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY CLINTON'S PRIVATE EMAIL
SERVER.
ACCORDING TO CARTER'S SOURCES,
McCABE WAS OVERSEAS WHEN HE
BECAME AWARE OF THE
INVESTIGATION AND SENT
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS
VOICING HIS DISPLEASURE WITH
AGENTS DOING THEIR JOB.
ONE FBI OFFICIAL TELLS
SARA CARTER "McCABE TRIED TO
STEER PEOPLE OFF THE PRIVATE
EMAIL INVESTIGATION THAT APPEARS
TO BE OBSTRUCTION AND SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED."
THIS OF COURSE COMES ON THE
HEELS OF THE IG REPORT ON
MCCABE'S FIRING REVEALING
"McCABE SAID THAT A
HIGH-RANKING OBAMA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT FBI AGENTS TAKING
OVERT STEPS IN THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION INVESTIGATION DURING
THE PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN."
IT'S CLEAR THAT DURING THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, THE DEEP
STATE AS WE HAVE NOW BEEN
REPORTING OVER A YEAR WAS ALIVE
AND WELL.
WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO ENTER